abide in harris
presidency would be a continuation of
the eight years of obama's time in the
white house
and i think it's fair to say if you know
a little bit
about foreign policy and the
consequences that it that it's had
all across the world from an outsider's
perspective
you don't want that and they're already
talking
about you know going into syria
president illegitimate as i call it
illegitimate president-elect
biden's team are talking about you know
going to syria already
we have had four incredible years
when it comes to um foreign policy
with president trump the stabilization
of the middle east after those eight
years of obama was such a relief
to me uh you look at the
the peace agreements between israel and
the different nations
in the in the region i mean you weren't
born either but you're i'm sure you know
about you know the three no's
in khartoum uh patrick you know where
all the leaders of the arab
league uh got together and said you know
no peace with israel
no recognition with israel no
negotiation with
israel right and to think that
since then since 1967 it's just been
conflict after conflict and bloodshed
after bloodshed
and and president trump comes in
and he was able to bring all these
people together at the table
to strike peace agreements
and he hasn't started any new wars
since taking office which people you
know said that it would be the end of
the world if
president trump um uh became president
and just i
i urge you know people to to properly go
and research
just in terms of foreign policy the
stark contrast and
who at the end of the day um
ushered in more peace president trump
or barack obama and then you know
obviously we can get into also
everything that's been done in terms of
domestic policy which has really
benefited
the american people you know the past
four years but
there's just the list as i wrote in my
letter to america in a more
succinct way but the list is quite long
of of trump's achievements
in um in retrospect after four years and
i
and i understand why the american people
over 70 million
of them would like four more years of uh
of president trump i'm not american and
i want
four more years too here's my question
for you you know if
trump was able to do what he did
um what he did with
uae and israel 25 years flight
kushner was on it unbelievable history
in the making
something nobody expected to happen why
is netanyahu
yeah why is netanyahu going out there
and congratulating
um a biden on
his being a president-elect while this
took place with trump and maybe he could
have waited
to say that why is netanyahu becoming so
friendly with biden so quickly
that's a good question the first wave of
um
world leaders who congratulated
illegitimate
president-elect biden were
trudeau macron and boris johnson
which already was quite you know
shocking in and of itself
and i believe netanyahu's message came
a couple of days after but apparently i
think as
of yesterday he retracted
and came out stating you know that uh
we had to wait and see what happens uh
with this fraud things
but you know it's quite telling um one
one thing one thing that is
positive throughout um this whole
process
it for me is that it's exposing a lot of
what is wrong with the system
and who is part of that said system and
who is not and i'm very encouraged you
know to see
you know the leaders of hungary or
poland or
brazil even the president of mexico
refused to congratulate
fake president-elect biden so
i think a lot of thing has a lot of
things have been revealed
in this process which undoubtedly
um needed to be brought to light in
order
for a full cleanup to take place and
this is what you know
i'm looking forward to i have faith you
know that
the proof will be taken to court and
that it will be irrefutable
and the process which i described in my
letter of
these forces that have sought to
undermine america for decades
entering you know like a trojan horse
and eroding her from within
through all the different realms of
society governmental and
intelligence agencies but you know
through the society whether it was media
entertainment
um news me
the media culture where you've had
people very intent on bringing america
down
and this is the main reason why i
support the president because i truly
believe
that i truly believe that this is what
he set out to do is to to clean out the
deep state
the swamp the globalists the cabal
whatever name you want to call them
but people who for their own reasons
and for their own personal benefits
need for america's standing to be
brought down to the level of certain
other nations
last question before we get into
speedrunner wrap up the interview is
uh what what what are the likelihood
of a 9 11 happening again
in america what's the likelihood of us
having another incident like 9 11 in u.s
this is a very good question um
you know lieutenant general flynn
when he was
[Music]
working with the obama administration
couldn't understand certain of the
policies
that barack obama was putting in place
with regards you know to isis in the
middle east
with regards to what was happening
domestically as well with certain cells
there was lots of things in terms of
not handling islamists
in a way that would protect america's
interests and national security
very valid he had very very valid
questions
um lieutenant general flynn and um
questions that really bothered uh obama
to the point that he was
you know relieved of his functions and
and the bravery of this man
cannot be uh overstated
because he went and spoke in media about
what was happening and all of that
so when you look at america and you see
these organizations such as care
and others and the how the muslim
brotherhood has embedded
society and this american society
and
contrast that with president trump and
what he what he did as soon as he
entered office you know which was this
um
temporary ban of certain countries
people call it the muslim ban but that's
not true
it was a ban of nine countries through
which terrorists are known to transit
and you know fly out from and
he instituted that saying a very valid
point until we figure out what's going
on
i need to preserve the national security
of my country right
so you have two very stark approaches to
allowing entry of
terrorists into the country and what i
mean by
there are more chances of a terrorist
attack happening on
u.s soil is that what you need to do and
which is what we've failed to do
here in europe thanks to angela merkel
and
others who decided to completely open
the floodgates and allow all the
terrorists to come in
this is what needs to be done you need
to close the borders
and and properly vet the people that are
coming in and this is not
racist right this is common sense of
protecting the citizens of your own
nation
and this is what i that this is what i
appreciate
with president trump is that he is
putting the security
of his nation first and
this has not been the case with barack
obama and this will not be the case
with um a biden harris administration